hello everyone and welcome back to the
things we're all very excited that
season eight of Dance Moms will be
airing on June 4th 2019 the new season
of this fan favorite series may be
missing some of our favorite girls but
that's okay because a new herd of
dancers are taking the stage fans are
curious to find out which one of Abby's
newest dancers will be taking Maddie's
place as number one keep watching to
find out who this person might be watch
out
Maddie recap season 8 of Dance Moms is
set to air on June 4th 2019 with Abby
Lee Miller back to her usual dynamics
while we didn't get the original team
back what we did get was a whole new set
of fresh faces and competitive little
dancers before we get started on all the
latest news and drama let's throw it way
back with a recap of the original Dance
Moms crew even though it seems like just
yesterday that we saw the girls take the
stage and line up for pyramid day the
first season of Dance Moms actually
debuted on lifetime back in 2011 making
it almost a decade since the start of
the show despite some amazing additions
to the dance team as the seasons went on
it's hard for fans to forget the six
girls who were there from the very
beginning we add Nia Frazier the only
dancer to stick it out until the very
end the Highland Sisters Brooke and
Paige who for many reasons ended up
leaving the show in its fourth season
the group sweetheart Chloe Lucchesi AK
whose rocky relationship with Abby led
her to leave Dance Moms only to return
for its final season there was also the
fact that she was constantly pitted
against her teammate and best friend at
the time Maddie Ziegler out of all of
the six girls Maddie and Mackenzie
Ziegler were arguably the ones given the
most attention throughout the show they
even grew up to have some of the most
successful Hollywood careers that the
dance world has ever seen
although a lot of this had to do with
their hard work and natural talent we
can definitely think of two other women
who may have helped the girls launch
their careers there is of course their
mother Melissa Casone
who constantly fought to make sure her
girls were on Abby's dance radar I just
want you to and Abby herself who
arguably played the largest hand in
Maddie's rise to fame throughout the
season she began to proudly prioritize
Maddie over her teammates and use her in
order to encourage
the girls to be more hard-working and
competitive this was done through a ton
of small but significant gestures on
Abby's part for starters maddie was
given a ton of extra class time that the
other girls were not she was also given
more solos than many of her other
teammates and found herself at the top
of the dance pyramid even when the other
girls felt they had deserved it more
what many people don't know about Dance
Moms is that despite Abby's constant
appearance on the show in real life the
girls rarely got to see her that is
unless it was time for their dance
competitions fine the scenes however
Abby is said to have spent a ton of time
with Maddie's mother Melissa it didn't
take long before the other Dance Moms
noticed the exceptional treatment that
the Ziegler girls were getting from
their dance teacher and so the Maddie
issue began
despite Maddie being extremely talented
and hardworking all in her own the other
Dance Moms resented that their children
weren't receiving the same love and
praise from their dance teacher they
insisted that it just wasn't fair since
they all pay the same tuition that
Maddie does to be there and that Maddie
was still the one being praised even
when another girl was the winning
soloist of the night Chloe recap it
didn't take long before
Abby's favoritism became too much for
Maddie's best friend at the time Chloe
Lucchesi at Chloe and her mother Christi
were constantly being compared to Maddie
and Melissa it's always all about her
daughter and no one else Abby even went
as far as to have Maddie and Chloe
compete in a dance-off backstage the
only twist was that it was their own
teammates judging the girls performances
with Abby even reading the results out
loud in front of the moms and dancers
this was totally harsh on Abby's part
and probably didn't feel great for
either Maddie or Chloe it was this kind
of treatment that led to Chloe and her
mother leaving the show and eventually
cutting all ties with Melissa Maddie and
Mackenzie this made everyone realized
that Abby was totally serious when she
said that everybody is replaceable
however Abby really did care for Maddie
a lot more than the other girls this led
the moms to openly acknowledge Maddie's
status on the team she even coined the
expression the next Maddie when talking
about Abby's up-and-coming favorites
this includes dancers like green room
follow and Kalani Hilliker season 8 cast
overview it
no secret that a brand-new cast is on
the horizon for season eight of Dance
Moms this season we'll start off with
its official new members
Brady Farrar Giannina how long Tonio
Anna Colin Sarah Georgiana Presley
Hasmukh
Savannah Cris ditch and returning minis
dancer Liliana catchman another minis
group members set to make an appearance
in season eight is Ileana Walmsley along
with newcomer Cameron Smith Cameron's
mother is reportedly trying to make sure
Cameron is able to have a normal
childhood and continue to go to school
regularly which could explain why she
will not be making an appearance for the
first few episodes now just looking at
this new squad of dancers we immediately
noticed that Abby had a pretty specific
team in mind for the new upcoming season
all of these dancers are already pretty
successful in the dance world and are
older than many of the original girls
when they made their Dance Moms debut
we've got Giannina who already has a ton
of working experience under her belt
this includes working on Broadway
dancing at the Rockefeller tree lighting
and even joining Mariah Carey on her
diva tour this little dancer even got to
play a role in the ballet scene of the
greatest showmen alongside stars like
Zac Efron and zendaya
while this new group of dancers is
definitely different than the original
Dance Moms girls we can still spot a few
similarities between the two groups that
might tell us just how this new story is
going to go after watching a sneak peek
of the newest season we can already spot
a lot of Chloe Lucas he acts kind and
sweet characteristics in dancer Hanna
Collins in a Dance Moms season eight
preview and I can be seen talking about
Abby's teaching style in a very
appreciative way and mentions how she
hopes to build lifelong friendships
they're all amazing dancers with the
rest of her teammates with Lily being
one of the younger dancers of the group
her goofiness reminds us of McKenzie
back when she started her Dance Moms
journey another dancer who stands out to
us is Cameron after some Instagram
digging we can already tell that Cameron
has a lot of that fiery personality we
can relate to one of our favorite
dancers Jojo CY while Cameron is a lot
younger than Jojo was when she first
made an appearance on the show we just
can't help but feel her confidence and
energy radiating through her dancing
before we get to our big question of who
the next Maddy will be we thought we
would also mention another dancer who is
constantly compared to Maddie throughout
her own time on Dance Moms
Brynn rum fellow for those of you who
need a quick recap on Brynn her and her
mother Ashley first made their
appearance on Dance Moms back in its
fifth season she first made her way onto
the team as a guest dancer from the club
dance along with her former teammate
Sarah reasons this is actually the same
studio that Kalani was a part of as well
now Sarah may have only been brought on
momentarily to help push Nia's
boundaries but it seems like Abby had
other plans for Brynn despite not
sticking around after her brief
appearance in season 5 Brynn was asked
to return for the show's sixth season
new season new rules it didn't take long
before Brynn became Abby's favorite
dancer Landing all of the group dances
starring roles and competition solos
Fran was even being referred to as the
next Maddie by all of the other Dance
Moms and of course Abby herself if Brit
really wants to be daddy's replacement
right now believe it or not that Abby
even admitted that Brynn is her favorite
since she is gorgeous skinny and blonde
this did not sit well with the other
moms and could explain why they treated
Brynn so harshly in the episodes that
followed if you'd like to catch up with
Brynn and see what she's been up to
since her Dance Moms days then you can
check out her YouTube page as for her
dancing we're afraid that you won't
catch Brend dancing anytime soon since
she says that the show actually killed
all of her passion for it if you were a
fan of brands personality and dance
style then not to worry because we seem
to have found another dancer to match
her characteristics in the latest season
this little dancer and the next Brynn is
none other than Presley Hasmukh
I'll only do her imprints mothers have
the same name but both of these girls
seem to have effortless talent along
with their laid-back and non problematic
personalities last but not least we've
got our amazing Ches team member while
it might be too soon in this season to
tell we definitely feel some of me Z's
hip-hop vibes and tough cookie
personality in dancers Sarah Georgiana
finally we've got a specific dancer in
mind for the question of who will be the
next Maddie Ziegler this dancer stands
out from the crowd in more ways than
just one and he's none other than Brady
Farrar from what we've heard Brady has
had no trouble keeping up with the
ladies he is also the first official and
starring member of The Dance Moms cast
making it pretty much impossible for
this young dancer not to stand out
despite being a total sweetheart with
his teammates this dancer is ultra
competitive when he's on stage and even
as fans comparing his dance style to
Maddie's now we all know that Abby
prioritizes dance skills above pretty
much everything else a dancer has to
offer
aside from star quality that is it isn't
hard to see that Abby's previous dancers
didn't lack a shred of talent but even
then only a handful of dancers had what
it took to catch Abby's attention
Abby clearly sees that very same star
power in Brady since he admits that
there have already been clashes between
the moms simply because Abby gives him
extra praise Abby can even be spotted
asking one of the mothers got jealous of
a 14 year old boy just like Maddie
though Brady maintains his relationship
with his teammates and seems to be very
close with all of them he mentions that
no matter what happens between their
moms they'll always be best friends
Brady seems to already be on his way to
a Maddie Ziegler level of Fame having
already danced on The Ellen Show as well
as Dancing with the Stars in our books
there really is nobody who can replace
Maddie Ziegler or any of the original
girls that this cast will undoubtedly
give them a run for their money
reddit user big brother zoom has posted
some of his season 8 predictions online
he thinks he has an idea of what the
next Dance Moms will be like he guesses
that Stacy Lily's mom will do whatever
she has to do to get Lily on top of the
pyramid just like Melissa
Yolanda on the other hand might feel
threatened by Lily's success and feud
with Stacy similarly to Christi Lukasiak
whatever the case we just hope that the
team will be able to put all of that
past drama behind them and focus on
supporting each other with Abby's track
record they're definitely going to need
all of the support and encouragement
they can get we will definitely be
tuning in to watch season 8 of Dance
Moms we can't wait to see what Abby and
the team accomplished if you're excited
to watch the upcoming
leave your favorite emoji in the comment
section who do you think the next Maddie
will be let us know in the comment
section below and that's a wrap be sure
to subscribe to the things and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching see you guys next
time
[Music]